[Music]
she's like buy it richer all Srimati
it's me welcome to the podcast I'm back
it's been a long time I think this is
the longest that we've gone I know what
started the show happening on what's
been going on with you I don't know it's
behind I just got caught up in all the
fancy people that I get to have on I
forgot in your life hey you're quietly
in the background waving your hand hi
I'm still here that's okay I appreciate
it I think I was on in August last was
it August yeah it's been almost a full
year so I don't know when this is gonna
air but we're in mid-july right now in
the wake of celebrating celebrating with
quotation marks around that we share our
anniversary celebration with all of you
yeah how are you feeling about the state
of our marriage I'm feeling very good
about the state of that's good even
though I have a bit honey here it's on
the record even though that there was no
really anniversary celebration even in
spite of those things and I feel really
good about our marriage actually I had
done for podcast interviews Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday and Friday
was our anniversary and I was so toasted
there was no shock for Srimati nothing
he gave it all I gave it every I gave it
to other people I had nothing left for
you I'm the worst when it comes to
holidays you're not really well I have a
resistance to dates on a calendar that
you know we're sort of socially
contracted to celebrate there's
something inside of me that rebels
against that and doesn't want to you
know basically play the game are you
saying that you're resentful that it was
our anniversary no I'm not saying that
I'm more resentful that somebody else
decides when we're supposed to celebrate
things yeah you're right right horrible
well we could celebrate right now so
there was no diamond ring or anything
like that I still don't have a diamond
ring I don't even wear wedding rings
actually well I'm glad that you're
feeling good about our marriage
I am I feel like we're all a couple
things I mean first we're sort of
entering into a new phase of our
relationship as two people that have
been together for a very long time and
which is really cool and interesting and
I don't know exciting I guess that's the
first thing the second thing I forgot
okay well that's good it's good you came
prepared
yeah well the typical thing happened
before we sat down yesterday I'm like
okay I want you to put some thought into
what we're gonna talk about today and
you just shrugged me off so the onus is
on you well we've established that I
function better in the moment that's I
can truly be here's the moment the
moment is right now so dance so dance
but you have to tell me what where you
want to go no sir shows it's on you know
yeah this is what you wanted this is
what you asked for
I want aeneas you were saying that you
were happy about it the state of our
marriage and you said it was good
because we are at a new moment and then
you said there was a second thing yeah I
just remember what that's like adding us
and leading um as two people that have
been together for 20 or 21 years at this
point right I'm not sure we started we
we got together in 1999 yeah because we
spent the millennium together right you
broke your wrist snowboarding I feel
like we've earned the right to not be
relationship experts I can tie averse to
that term but we have experienced media
and a little bit of wisdom we do that we
can share we have truth I think this is
your diving board and your launching off
yeah well I do actually consider myself
an excerpt expert in relationship and
that's because you are my third foray
into the marriage you always like to
bring that up I like to just be a minute
you don't know why let's focus on us
okay let's all right you can context no
so it makes it does make me a
relationship expert because I have that
history so I have these
I had you know a very hellish abusive
marriage I had a very romantic fairytale
marriage and now I have the marriage you
know I got to burst the fairy tale you
did it kind of how I feel about that you
should feel good about it because it's
really it's a really real thing and it's
an it's an amazing thing when you can
break through that not that we don't
love romance or not that we don't enjoy
those kind of interactions but I think
when you are truly meeting in all
aspects of the relationship when you're
you're taking responsibility to create
your own fulfillment within your own
self there really is no Prince princess
fairy tale paradigm and in fact when you
play in that paradigm it's actually it's
actually a dishonouring a dishonouring
of the Divine Being because as life
forms each of us have enough energy
within ourselves to fulfill our divine
mission or our blueprint or our sole
mission or the reason that we're in this
life right so in other words if you're
overly invested in another human being
to take care of certain things for you
then you're basically hamstringing or
handicapping yourself because that power
and resilience and energy and self
sufficiency lives within you yeah
definitely and if you feel like it is
your job or your mission to fix another
person or fulfill that in another person
and that gives you a sense of pride or
or like importance you're in fact
hindering that individual from truly
becoming themselves so how am i doing in
that regard you're doing great and you
always have from the very beginning and
I've shared let you be you well you let
me be me and you also I think because of
your recovery and I really credit the
fact that you are in a 12-step program
and that you have the recovery tools you
know in your experience coupled with my
spiritual perspective we have a pretty
powerful toolbox to you know take out
and dive into when we get into trouble
or when we
step into something that very that is
very very intense and when I first met
you one of the most amazing things you
ever said to me was I see you're in pain
and I feel for you I'm compassionate
towards you but I have nothing to do
with that pain and I don't know how to
help you like I don't have the answers
and you were one of the first male
relationships in my life that said to me
I don't have the answers for you and
that was like a breath of fresh air to
me because when you have somebody who
who claims they always have the answers
for you or they know better or they're
trying to sort of guide or rule your
life or assess your life or analyze your
life inherent in those actions is a
distrust and a non belief in you in me
and it feels like an oppression or like
a like a suppression or a a pressing
down a keeping down of the energy of
what wanted to come through me as a
woman as you know as my own life for him
as my own divine life-form that has all
the energy she needs to fulfill herself
within herself
well the conventional male/female
relationship paradigm is one in which
the man comes into a conflict or a
predicament with this overwhelming
impulse to just fix it and make it right
or say this is what you need to do like
let's resolve this and the conventional
female perspective is I don't want to I
don't want you to fix it I don't need
you to fix it I just want to be heard
and acknowledged is that yeah it could
be I mean I think it you know I think
some women do want men to fix it and I
think they're still living in that
paradigm and you know that was a big
cornerstone of how we went through nine
years financial collapse and
transforming into living our dreams and
the fact that I wasn't yelling at you to
go get a job or I wasn't putting the
onus on you to fix all the financial
issues
and so I I felt at that time like I
believe in living what is in the heart
in finding what is in the heart and
serving the heart the heart is the
divine mind not the brain so if I wanted
that for myself which I do and I want
that for my children I had to want that
for my husband even though times were
hard I couldn't say well I'm finding my
divine voice and you go clock in at the
law firm and make everything fine right
so somehow I knew because I had this
extreme faith I had this knowing in this
awareness that the way through these
challenges was to really find out what
was the truth of each of our hearts and
to do everything that we could to
fulfill that and that some way by some
grace by some miracle or some divine
intervention that somehow our lives
would be ordered in a way that it would
support that expression was there ever a
moment where you thought it was too much
and you were like this is not working
and I'm ready to give up there was one
moment and it was when we had almost
come through we were coming through and
it was when you dnf'd at ultraman and
you relapsed and in the wake of that
after having held space for you for so
many years I mean through such adversity
and such friction and tension it was
hard for me to imagine that you would
make that choice because I'm not an
addict and I wasn't in that frame but at
that moment I had a moment where I was
like have I misjudged who riches have I
misjudged him because we're just
arriving out of this battle and we're
actually being realized and this is the
choice he made in that moment yeah that
was a low moment that was a rough that
was a rough experience to navigate
through I mean the level of like shame
and sense of disappointment that I had
that I'd let myself down and you down
and this whole plan
down was very difficult but in
retrospect now having you know many
years passed since then like how do you
look back on that experience it was you
know it was still a hard moment I mean
it was a it was a moment of you know are
you [ __ ] kidding me
quite frankly you know it was you know
super difficult I mean again I've said
it before I was grateful for your
community and AAA and all the guys that
you have around you so many beautiful
men that are in your life as a part of
that program and you know they were
right there and you know Tyler was there
and you know you got you know you got
righted like right away like it wasn't
it wasn't a long it wasn't a long spell
in that but I do remember arriving back
from Hawaii and I had supported you in
your expression through all of these
years and I was a gave birth to Jaya and
was really sort of in this seclusion at
home with the kids and doing ceremony
and spiritual practices and ritual and
holding this vision for us and then
started creating the food and the
recipes and I had written two albums and
and become musician along with Tyler and
trapper our oldest sons and so I was
finally at the moment where I was going
to get to record my album and it had
been years it was seven years of working
workshopping these songs and so right
after that moment when we arrived back
home that was my turn
that was when Brad was coming here with
his a recording gear we were setting up
a studio in the house
I had him booked for 10 days to two
weeks and we were recording my first
album so part of me what I did is I took
my anger and put it to the side because
I wasn't going to let that ruin my
experience of music so I sort of just
was like okay I don't like this and this
has really upset me and rich is fine now
and he's working it out and so I'm gonna
put this to the side for the moment and
I'm gonna focus on this creative
expression and then what happened is the
boys dad died
suddenly and tragically on day three of
my recording session so what I endured
at the end of that year 2011 was pretty
staggering I mean a pretty pretty
intense sort of energetic experience
that I had to traverse through after
having held that vision for us for so
long and even though I hadn't been with
the boys dad for 14 years he was very
close in their lives and very close to
me and I had to process that grief
through myself so it was still many many
months and many many things before my
music came to fruition and by that time
I guess we had just worked it all out
right yeah but I suspect it made you a
stronger person to have to endure all of
that and navigate the difficulties of
the complex difficulties of loss anger
creative output parenting and just the
general responsibilities of having to
you know get through the day I mean even
though yes we were emerging from our
financial difficulties we were by no
means out of the woods at that point I
mean there was still quite a ways to go
and we would dip deeper before we kind
of really emerged out of it it's true
it's true I mean what I would say from
my perspective of that I would say that
it was a full experience of life that I
that I experienced and that experience
was full of heartbreak loss tragedy
triumph creative connection and the
weirdest thing was during the days
following the death of the boy's father
Lou I felt a simultaneous experience of
grief and birth and it's not something
that I've ever spoken about before I
probably never told you about this
before but it was a very profound
dichotomy of this jux juxtaposition of
two extremes
maybe the same thing and so it was an
extremely profound potent really deep
experience his exit from this world was
one of the most profound experiences
that I've had and it's because there
were all these synchronicities and signs
that were in the music in people that I
met just coincidences and and in things
that happened during that time
and I really did feel the presence of
divinity in that space I felt that it
was it was met I remember when you were
racing and Ultraman Lou was texting me
and he was checking you he was following
the race and that was kind of a first
because it's not like we were just you
know we were really good getting
divorced and really took care of the
children but it's not like we were
hanging out all the time no I mean Lou
wasn't Lou was great but he wasn't like
my buddy
you know we weren't friends but he was
you know kind and respectful and we you
know we we all handled it like grown-ups
you know but it's not like we were
taking vacations together or something
like that so he was following your race
in those last days yeah he was texting
me and really excited and and all of
that and so I think that that it was
just I forgot my train of thought what I
was just saying but anyway it was a it
was a divinity in the experience yeah it
was very very divine I mean there were
other things that happened like Lou's
first cousin mine I was very close with
her and when I was married to him and I
hadn't talked to her in like we hadn't
been together for 14 years I didn't talk
to her for 14 years so when he passed we
were in contact and she couldn't attend
the memorial service that I facilitated
that I officiated here in our home you
know I told the boys now it's a healing
project that's basically what it is it's
a healing mission and we had everyone
come in you know from his life past
business associates past lovers wives
girlfriends you know everyone was here
all of his lovely covet cousins the
Pyatt family
in an amazing group of individuals and I
officiated that that process for all of
us and it was really really beautiful a
miner couldn't come because she had been
given she had bought a trip for her
girlfriend and they were going to kawaii
and everything had already been booked
and bought and everything else so at
that time Sol Rey who's a you know
well-known renowned yoga teacher that
you know I grew up in yoga with and he's
been a great Ally and a great friend to
me and to us he you know emailed here
texted me and he was like Srimati like
could you come and cook for my retreat
and he said he knows that I have a
special connection to secret Beach on
kawaii
he said it's near secret Beach I don't
know if I'm asking too much but I think
it would be good and I could pay you we
needed money so I asked the boys and
they said go ahead and go mom so I went
there and I remember cooking completely
in grief and Saul would say what's on
the menu and I would say I have no idea
but something will be there and I
literally couldn't even make a menu list
because I was in such grief so my nakhon
tax me she's on kawaii at the same time
I haven't seen her in 14 years and I
said I'm I'm on the island meet me at
the Hindu temple at morning puja so I'm
sitting in the temple and she slides up
right next to me and we sit together for
puja and we took those flowers from the
offering from the priests that day and
we went down to secret beach and we
walked and we reminisced about Lou and
we offered these flowers into the ocean
so there were many many profound things
that happened during this time also
connected to my music Tyler and I were
recording in the Sun which is a song
that I wrote about you and I wrote about
the pressure of life and the financial
constriction and how hard it is in this
world you know especially for men to to
earn enough and be enough and succeed
and the chorus of this song was fly
daddy fly fly daddy fly and I had
written that chorus on a previous return
on the island of Kauai II from doing
spiritual practice and I had asked for
the chorus and that's what was given mmm
so years later after the boys and I
workshop this song over seven years in
many different forms Tyler and I even
had sung it on the Big Island during
that trip when you dnf'd we walked up to
the local music store and we played it
and sang it in the store and when we
finished we looked up and the shop owner
had broken down sobbing in tears and she
said I'm so sorry like you just it
touched me it touched me we walked out
and Tyler looked at me and he was like
okay that was good like as a musician if
you can make somebody cry with your song
like that's a good sign so here we were
the boys had said you know Mom we know
you wrote that song about rich but we
also think it's about Lou and it is it's
about everyman and so we would find out
later that when Lou called 911 he had a
heart attack on a kayak when he called
9-1-1 Tyler and I were actually
recording that exact song so the actual
recording on the album mother of mine is
the exact track at the moment that Lou
left his body that he left this world
and moved to another realm and what was
shown to me during that time when I met
Lou I was in an abusive marriage and I
was a battered woman I was on the out of
it I was coming out of it but that's the
truth that's the ugly truth and Lou
rescued me he truly was a rescuer that
was his archetype and that and he was a
fix-it man he was like I'm gonna fix
your life for you you know and he really
did my creative trajectory when I was
married to him was like a rocket I mean
I became an artist a fashion designer
started my own collection this was all
from being in a relationship where I
couldn't even take a step without
second-guessing myself and what I was
shown through this experience what I
felt is that Lou had rescued me in this
world and I had rescued him into the
other world
because I knew the spiritual essence and
the practices and the rituals and the
awareness to actually get him out of his
body and get him into the other realm
and the boys were sequestered here
safely at our sacred home at Jay house
we were recording music like it was it
just felt like it was all sort of
divinely planned and you know I haven't
spoken about it very much because it's a
very very private and very dear thing
but it was a profound experience that's
beautifully put
I remember I was out running on the
trails when my phone rang you said you
have to come home right now and you told
me what what had happened yeah and the
I'm gonna try to say it without without
crying but um - it was a horrifying
experience to wake your children up to
tell him that story you know and I
remember we had a Ganesh and I told
Malthus ahead of time and Malthus was
much younger like five or six right just
turned six eh yeah so she was like mom
why are you crying where you're crying
and I told her I said I have to wake the
boys up and I have to tell them that
their dad is gone and I woke them up and
we gathered around the Ganesh and I
wrapped them in the Poncho's that we got
on our retreats in Mexico and you know I
told them and and hours afterwards I
went upstairs to take a bath and I
remember math is coming in little baby
and she said to me mama she said you did
the very best you could you did such a
good job you did the very best that you
could and that was just a you know a
beautiful beautiful moment of this
experience with our children and how
how amazing they are and how how
powerful they are and how wise they are
and what they offer us you know in those
moments I mean I remember that moment
pretty vividly and I couldn't help but
think this is that moment where
innocence is now lost yeah and the harsh
reality of the world you know dawns upon
them yeah
so we're how old I think there were 14
and 15 yeah something like that yeah and
the other thing is is you know anybody
that's met Tyler and trapper there they
have all the best aspects of their dad I
mean they're extraordinary individuals
and as young men who they are I mean any
child but we just really felt like they
didn't deserve this
like this wasn't you know this wasn't a
fate that seemed akin to them and I mean
you say that and also it also came on
the heels of all the hardship that you
know they had to endure because of the
struggles that we were having and it's
so it was like a sucker punch yeah you
know at a vulnerable moment that was
already very raw and vulnerable yes yeah
it's true and what I want to share and
what I did learn from this experience
and I think it it might be useful to
others is is uh when we have children
with people and we those contracts come
to completion because being somebody
that's married been married three times
I do believe I don't believe there's one
soul mate for us I believe there's many
and it's a lot about divine timing and
it's a lot about these contracts that we
have that we enter into relationships
with people and then they come to
completion and they're complete so it's
not that it was a failure it's that the
experience the work or the exchange or
that alchemy is now complete and
sometimes that includes having children
and so we have you know divorced
families or mixed households but what I
do want to remind everybody in something
that I learned is that when you have
children with somebody you share an
energetic structure but it was it's
within your being
and even though I hadn't been with Lou
for 14 years I didn't want to be with
Lou was happily married to you and we
have new kids you know other kids and
and it was it was I was never longing to
be back there it was complete right but
when he passed the boys grief passed
through me as their mother and so what I
realized and that was like oh like you
can't separate that energetic and we
understood spiritually that he was no
longer here
I knew it immediately we weren't we
weren't angry at life we weren't trying
to you know reconcile or change fate or
whatever we we well understood we had
deep spiritual tools you know I've had
sessions where I've interacted with him
with other guides so I have an expanded
experience of Lou and where he is but
what I would say is that you cannot
bypass the grief that must pass through
your body because we are physical and we
are in a physical container a physical
life form and the one thing that I would
offer to parents that have these
contracts that have come to completion
this is another reason why it's so
important to maintain a level of respect
and dignity around those that you have
co-created with because those
individuals share aspects of that other
person and so if you're speaking badly
or choosing to view your partner in a
lower vibration you are including the
children in that unawareness in that
misstep in that imbalanced choice so the
more that you can see the good you can
hold the good the higher vision and
speak that you know about your partner
that you are no longer with this in
facts fortifies the children and helps
the children to be whole yeah I think
that's super important but also very
difficult to put into practice
in my experience of watching other
people navigate the vicissitudes of
breaking up like we've been together for
long enough to be privy to lots of
relationships over the years that that
haven't made it like I feel very
grateful that we're in this place and we
feel connected and you know our intimacy
is in check and we continue to grow and
support each other emotionally and all
of these good things like I don't take
that for granted at all because I think
it's it's rare and perhaps even
increasingly more and more rare but I
have you know noticed watching friends
and colleagues and other people figure
out how to move forward after a breakup
that often times the partners will
intend to maintain that level of
integrity like we're going we're not
going to go the divorce route of going
to court and all of that we're gonna
keep this super cool and we're friends
and you know the that with the best of
intentions right but then something
happens along the way and cracks in that
firmament begin to appear and before you
know it that there's a de evolution that
takes place where suddenly there is a
bunch of smack talking in front of the
kids and you know it really takes a turn
for the worse
and it's heartbreaking to see that I'm
empathetic because most of these people
that I know that have gone through this
are really good people and and they do
have the best of intentions but
something takes place that kind of kicks
it into a different climate where their
lower instincts kind of take control
it's true and I have a little bit to
offer on that from experience and I
would say that consciously they say
consciously uncouple uncoupling now but
consciously you know making and making
an intention to to separate you know in
Grace's is no easy path it is a
warrior's path it takes fierce
commitment
and you have to eat your ego so much so
let me be clear when Lou and I divorced
you know I I will say both of us I mean
you know I want to say he did a lot of
stuff I didn't like I'm sure I did a lot
of stuff he didn't like so I did say but
I'd say it's both partners will do
things that are not in alignment we are
not perfect people okay someone will
make a stupid move and do a stupid thing
and you know bring a relationship in and
you know in front of the kids or you
know whatever do something that's really
you know that's really wrong that's
really not right right in all of those
situations a really great practice is to
separate the action from the soul so
it's the same thing with any with anyone
you love as you can say to yourself I do
not like what he did or what she did but
I loved her I loved him I loved them at
a soul level so I'm gonna separate that
deep deep you know connection to the
truth of who they are and I'm still
gonna hold that highest vision for them
even if they've done the dumbest thing
that is so you know vile or so attacking
or whatever it is if you can be powerful
enough to hold that neutral and to hold
that vision and say okay I'm gonna allow
my personality to be upset about the
actions of the individual but I'm gonna
hold the highest divinity and I'm gonna
remember we created these children in
love and there were times where we were
so divine and things were so amazing and
this is a good person and let me remind
myself of all the good qualities of this
person so you have to understand this
person is suffering this person is going
through a change of everything they know
they're grasping for some kind of
stability whether you're the lever or
the levy
it's never easy it's not fun to get
divorced and it doesn't matter how much
you wanted it you will still process the
pain and the loss yeah so if you can
just keep that in your awareness you
will do much better and if you can find
every
opportunity to speak highly of the
person that you created these children
with there has to be some attribute
about something of the person that is a
beautiful quality or you wouldn't have
had children with them to begin with so
there has to be something and so that's
a that's a very very powerful tool that
you can you can choose to practice it is
a choice of perspective and society will
want to drag you into name-calling
Society will want you to meet their pain
in the destruction and the failure of
divorce but you can make a different
choice you can choose a perspective yes
you know people would say oh I'm so
sorry it didn't work out and I would say
oh no it worked out beautifully it was a
magnificent experience we spent 10 years
together we had amazing children we
created amazing creative projects that
experience came to completion and even
about my abusive relationship oh it was
a divine experience literally
transformed me taught me so much
he is my divine teacher mm-hmm how did
you feel about that in the moment
horrible yeah no right well I mean it's
I'm just I'm just trying to place myself
in the position of somebody who's
sitting in that and angst at the moment
and to say to that person when the other
partner is doing something that you
don't agree with or you know be
misbehaving just say take the higher
ground
you know shine that person with love I
mean that is the path forward ultimately
you're playing the long game
it may not solve the specific issue in
the moment but truly it is the only way
to move forward and free yourself from
the triggers of you know fear and anger
and resentments and whatever else is
boiling up yeah it's it's really really
hard and I mean I would use that's why
the abusive relationship that I wasn't
that I was in has been such a
magnificent teacher I mean first of all
let me just say that I was kind of I was
kind of arrogant I was
little bit flippant I was toying with
you know male attention you know I was I
was a young girl you know and in my
early 20s and you know what that
relationship taught me it taught me to
really cherish people who are kind
that's what it taught me you know when
when you've been on the receiving end of
something very very ugly for a long time
that is you know potentially ruining
your life you come to very very much
respect people who are kind and I think
in the beginning you know being in my
late teens and early 20s I was you know
a little bit flip in and thought I knew
everything and all that you know we go
through and you know the other thing is
what I learned and that experience is
that every solution is resolved within
your own being all the power for your
experiences within your own being it's
not about the other person who so it's
not what the other person is doing
it's who are you in the face of what is
going on and what are you who are you
big enough to hold that vibration and to
stop her taking in this exchange and you
know I had a therapist say to me during
the time you know that fighting is
[ __ ] it's the same thing so if you're
fighting a lot with who you're in
relationship with it's just another form
of the engagement right so are you
really done or are you just in there
still duking it out so when are you
gonna stop that cycle and and also we
have to understand that our partners are
not ourselves so like in my case Lou was
very very upset that I wasn't giving the
boys meat you know he was like you know
I'm concerned for their well-being and
he was trying to you know push meat on
them when they were there and they were
pretty bonded to me and didn't really
eat me very much so I was fine because I
had I'm you know I think as the mother
at that age I just had a lot of
influence over them but I didn't spend
time being angry at him or make that a
reason why we should fight because then
the kids were in an experience of
fighting and the most important thing
was for them to feel a peace and a
community and a respect and a dignity
between their parents and so I I would
choose that over
you know whose turn is it to have the
kids or not and in our case we both
adore to our kids and wanted them with
us all the time as I believe most
parents do and we never let them stay
with a third person we took them every
time if Lou had a business trip he just
said I'm leaving I said great I'll take
him you know or if I had to go he said
hunt you know honey bring them I'll take
them so there is a way to do this in a
positive way and get our own deal with
our own trauma and hurts and fears and
losses within ourselves and try to keep
the environment pretty clean for the
kids you know yeah I think that that in
a lot of these cases I would say I would
contend almost invariably each parent is
going to have their own unique parenting
style and they're gonna have different
priorities and and ways in which they
want to raise their kids and when you
split up and the kids are vacillating
between two households those differences
are gonna get exacerbated because there
isn't necessarily a meeting of the minds
about you know how much you know time on
the devices is there gonna be how you
know how much time to homework and what
is the you know whatever it is and I
think when one parent gets involved in
trying to control or change the way the
other parent is attempting to parent
those children that's where a lot of
conflict arises and I've seen this
happen so I think recognizing that you
have to release control over that and
allow that other person to pare it the
way that they want and that you get to
have domain over that when the kids are
in your house it's really the only
healthy choice that you can make I think
it is I mean I think it's the most
peaceful aware choice you can make and
you know from my standpoint I believe
that we all choose our parents to create
a certain field to that will that will
seed and grow a certain experience that
is for our own evolution so every being
has chosen the parental form that
they're incarnated into
no matter what that parent is doing that
is part of their evolution and so by you
getting involved in trying to change it
or shift it or judge it or make it wrong
you're in fact taking some of their
experience from them even if that's
difficult experience mm-hmm I like this
idea of reframing societal and social
expectations around relationships to
remove the shame associated with a split
by just relabeling it as completed and I
think it gives people freedom because
when somebody's relationship goes off
the rails or whether they're married or
not there's so much emotional energy
invested in it a but then there's all
these external pressures that get
layered on top of that that make people
feel bad if they make the decision to
like move away from it right there's
there's this sense of failure and I
think when you start to think of it as a
cycle that has completed that's now
allowed you to move on and and you know
embrace a different kind of relationship
is a much healthier way to look at it
and I think it's applicable not just in
romantic relationships but in in our
professional lives or with mentors like
a mentor can come in and serve a certain
role for an individual to catalyze
growth to a certain point and then that
growth curve is you know Peaks out and
is completed and it's time for somebody
else to enter your life and serve a role
and likewise or conversely we all do
that in similar ways for other people
yeah definitely and I mean what is what
is the triumph of staying married to
somebody that you're a completely made
it that's just holding on right you know
like a try trying not to drink yeah it's
just it is a societal and you know
listen I mean I'm a very monogamous
person you know I and I think you are
too so we don't really have that you
know polyamorous situation in our make
so we are very committed we find freedom
and commitment but yeah I mean the life
is about the journey in the same way
even in this you know abusive experience
that I found myself in in the early days
you know I was really pissed like I had
a hard time even imagining that I would
take responsibility for any of this
because none of this was sourcing from
me and what he would try to brainwash me
into believing was that I made him hit
me so that was that was basically the
the abusive cycle and it was a classic
cycle so it took me a long time but I
realized later down the road just you
know maybe a couple years down after I'd
lick my wounds for a long time
I realized that that until I took my own
responsibility for being in the
relationship and allowing him to treat
me that way
that I would still be in bondage to this
nightmare that had been such a big
teacher in my life and so by owning the
fact that I'm a creator and
understanding that that was a karmic
experience that I had to experience in
order to burn it or that it was for my
evolution and I experienced a lot of
evolution in that relationship and I
think that evolution is what allows me
to have the type of relationship that I
have with you today
so it's in the freedom of taking
responsibility that we free ourselves
and once again we go back to what I'm
seeking for you at this moment at this
precipice which it's good that we have
the cameras on and the mics on because
we have what are you gonna say well I'm
I'm really ready for the next evolution
of what this relationship is and I mean
for for better or worse worse or like it
or not I mean you and I are very
different individuals we are maybe
extremely different and somehow we have
been put together by divine mother for
this journey that has ignited some
inspiration some vision for you know for
many who you know write to us who want
to know how
we are in relationship and the fact that
we are so extreme that you know sort of
everything about the way we walk the
earth is completely different the way we
approach the earth the way we experience
life and I'm looking for now this next
level of evolution and expansion when we
are truly igniting both feminine and
masculine energies within ourselves and
as we access these greater energies of
fully stepping into our power how does
that look in a new paradigm relationship
and so we have traces and aspects of
this prince/princess paradigm that we
you know we've that we've played into
that have worked for us and it is a
human way of relating man and wife and I
feel like we are on the precipice of
writing a new way of being relate in
relationship and and what does that mean
and so for me to be clear because I can
see you're like you're like can you make
a list can you no I'm not but I do want
ya flush that out so I know exactly what
I mean I'm looking for first of all more
ceremony in our marriage I'm look but
I'm looking for it not in not in that
I'm doing it and you're going along with
it I'm looking for a recognition and a
knowing of the power of ritual and
ceremony and as we move through life the
letting go of our habits of watching
Netflix of watching you know movies
whatever those humanly activities are
that that gather our attention for a
moment I'm looking for an expansion into
really understanding that a life is
precious and every moment we spend is
precious and now that we know that we've
been given the privilege of being in
this space of having an audience of
having people that we can commune with
really committing to using that time and
using that time in relationship so we're
back to the anniversary no date no
celebration
the reason why I wasn't really attached
to it is I didn't want to go to dinner
with you I don't want to go to a movie
with you I don't want to go do some
typical anniversary esque you know I
don't want a dozen roses from you I want
to go on the side of a cliff and like
take our clothes off and you know right
as you know light a ceremonial fire not
really because their fires around here
but you know what I'm saying I mean I
want to explore what can we really do
together that's beyond I've gone to
enough dinners I've had enough roses I
don't need to go to another dinner I
don't need to go to we can't even go to
hotel room because you sleep in a tent
so unless we bring the tent to the hotel
right no I get what you're saying
so do you okay yeah and I and I'm I'm up
for that
you know I'm up for that new experience
and I think it would it would cultivate
a an enhanced level of intimacy that
would take us into this next chapter and
I think just doing a retrospective on on
you know where we're at and how we got
here I look at it like this we we got
together for whatever reason to
co-create we committed to this path less
trodden we underwent difficulties we
burned in the fire almost died yeah to
emerge from that and then we're
presented with opportunities that I
think over the last seven years whatever
it is eight years I have just worked my
ass off to capitalize on in order to
create stability for the family and also
almost as in amends for the trauma that
preceded it and to proved to myself that
I could be a successful productive
member of society which is something I
had previously struggled with my entire
life or at least beginning when I
started started drinking and I've been
in kind of crisis mode
for that entire eight-year period just
trying to make it work and now we've
emerged from that with a situation that
is successful its staple I've got this
platform I'm able to provide for the
family and essentially I'm in this
incredibly privileged rare situation
where I get to make choices about where
I want to place my energy and make money
like I am essentially in control of that
but I'm still operating day to day like
I'm in that triage situation and this
has been impressed upon me by many
people to just listen you you can take a
minute here and breathe and relax and
I'm like how about I got to do this and
then this is happening and it's like
yeah five years ago you had to be that
way
maybe two years ago you had to be that
way but now you don't have to be that
way and what is it all worth if you
can't really feel gratitude moments a
moment for what you have co-created and
to be present in your own life and
that's something that I definitely
struggle with moment to moment and
something that I want to be able to
embrace and bring into my life in a more
meaningful way and it's that's a
challenge for me you know because I'm
running I'm running this program and the
fear associated with flipping the switch
and doing it a different way gets
associated in my mind with stopping you
know like an arresting of the things
that got me here right like this is the
way I do it and this is what's working
to do it anyway differently would mean
risking capsizing the whole thing mm-hmm
well first of all I want to say thank
you that you have done an extraordinary
job of coming into this level of
expression and it's absolutely beautiful
to see and it's breathtaking and that
has been an amazing experience
aryans for all of us definitely I would
also say again that in a human format we
like to make a list and say from the
brain that we have all these things to
do first and then we'll get to the
spirituality and so what we have to
remember and what I will remind you is
it is the purity of this relationship
that fruited this entire drama the
entire thing that we're doing so it
started on a very special day well it
started before but the day that we
actually were married it was a spiritual
world concert there were channelers
Bhagavad Das kirtan gospel singers
African wedding dancers and it literally
was all about spirituality and it was
one of the most beautiful days in my
life I posted it on our anniversary on
my Instagram feed that ceremony is what
was the intention that created what we
experienced now are you connected with
that yeah okay so what I'm saying is
that I just wanted to check in you're
like yeah I was okay no it it is that
level of desire of devotion it's really
this devotion this this this love affair
with life the love affair with the
wonder of life and what is pulsing
through each one of us and all life and
so what I would say to you is that you
don't have to change the format of how
you run the podcast make sure you can
shift and all that and you know we're
going to be taking some time off in
December which is magnificent
so all of that is great but I guess what
I'm talking to more is in the day-to-day
of how you go about your day I know
there is time that is spent either in
this for all of us I'm not like judging
I'm just saying it's social media it's
scrolling through Twitter it's Netflix
it's it's stuff that we do out of habit
stuff that we do out of habit and this
would be good for everybody what if we
all made a list for
next week of things we do out of habit
that are not high vibrational activities
that are furthering the life that are
actually met being medicated or being
suppressed or controlled by the society
to check out what we are serving as
medication yeah but we just do it by
default because we don't really even
we're not really thinking of it we're
like okay I worked a hard day now I
deserve an episode of Han man's head
made today because I just want to
distract myself and I just want to
breathe and just can I just not think
about my life right now and invest in
some story that all that'll lull me into
a sleep state but what if you like chose
let's not ask you to give it all up
let's just say if just one day a week
there was a two-hour time period where
you turned all the lights off and turned
on a candle and you actually communed
with the greater being that you are and
you were like you know like when I sit
in that it's like you know lead me guide
me direct me reveal yourself to me like
reveal the path to me I'm here I'm here
I'm listening I'm listening so what I'm
asking is what would happen are in our
relationship if we used our beautiful
intimacy our divine sexual connection
our wonderful a parent play of opposites
what if we actually seeped that
consciously in devotion not from not
just from my side because all these
years I've been holding this I've been
doing this the countless ceremonies the
countless you know rituals that I've
done for years and years and years and
years what I'm saying is that we have an
opportunity to actually step into this
in the next level and it's a level of
visioning it's a level of taking
responsibility and it's a level of
saying okay we're available you've shown
us the divinity of our of our extremes
together in relationship and now we know
that it's a new time on planet Earth and
that we have an opportunity to move into
a new kind of relationship so lead us so
we're here we're here
we're listening it doesn't have to be
like a big thing but it could just be
that what if that was devoted to us
instead of you going to group instead or
maybe in addition but it seems like
again it's like if this relationship
just like everything if it's always the
last thing because you think it's always
going to be to get be here then that's
the danger or that's the misstep because
it's not necessarily it's not nothing
that is on uncared-for unacknowledged or
you know not not given the energy then
that thing doesn't grow it doesn't
change it doesn't shift and so as you
and I are kind of veterans and we're
entering I cracked up the other day
because I've had a couple moments you
know I was reflecting before we went to
plant para Talia which I wanted to talk
about a little bit and on the way there
you know I was thinking well I wonder if
this is going to be the last event that
I do with rich because I know
spiritually I'm moving into a different
arena you know I'm also evolving beyond
what I've experienced in the past and I
was like yeah I'm kind of prepared I
don't really know how this group is
gonna receive me and then when we went
through it like like I was shown they
are exponentially like off the hook
broad anything we've gone and I should I
should add that I went into it thinking
this is probably the last time that
we're gonna do it as well and and that's
informed in part by just how taxing the
travel is and it's in the same location
it's like the world's a big place why we
keep going to the same farm and it's
amazing and beautiful and wonderful and
it works for what we do but I was kind
of like am i over this like are we done
like let's go through this week and
that'll probably be it but go ahead yeah
and I mean you know it's not your second
nature it's not something that you would
do it is my sights your Jarmo to sit
with people and commune and you know I
can speak to hundreds of thousands of
people you know through the microphone
and iPhone
my Dharma more in that yes but the one
on one kind of tutelage dynamic is not
like I I can do it but I have to really
gear up for it and suit up whereas you
can just pop into that and it gives you
energy and for me it's draining yeah
it's true
and that's a difference and luckily
you've gone along because at the end of
the week would it what did you say so
yeah so we have this experience with
these it was our biggest group how many
52 people total but but I think eight of
those were Christophe big group of
people and it was just utterly
transformative for everybody who
attended and in the aftermath of it it
was like we have to do that we have to
well I guess we're coming back next year
I keep doing this you know it was just -
it was - moving and - impactful and and
too emotional to ignore that there I
think the point that you're driving
towards is there's something about the
uniting of our differing energies that
you know catalyze is something powerful
that neither of us can do on our own and
as we continue to evolve and evolve
separately and develop our respective
little worlds of what we do that when we
occasionally come together in that Venn
diagram overlaps for you know a specific
purpose that there's something unique
and cool and powerful about that that
speaks to and is endemic in the energy
that birthed this whole thing that we
get to do in the first place yeah it is
I mean it's it's profound literally
profound what happens and it's happened
every single trip it's just this was
like exponential like activated I think
it has to do with planetary conditions
and it also has to do with the fact that
I went to DOM and heard before so I had
this energy of the spiritual community
that I had slept in the temples for
three days and so we were really primed
for a really amazing experience but it
was a delightful surprise and this is a
huge amount of work for us as well I
mean it's not like you know you see the
pictures on Instagram and it's like
you know but it's a lot to hold space
for that many people
I do thrive in it and I and I love it
it's a profound experience and and I
consider it a privilege that you and I
have been paired and that this has been
what has been revealed through our
relationship and so as we I was laughing
I was in my meditation office down in
the garden where I sit every morning in
the middle of a sage disappear in the
morning and go down the hill by the
teepee and do some kind of I don't know
mystical hijinks down there and then you
come back reappear it's a such a
beautiful beautiful time to connect but
I was giggling up myself because you're
I'm reflecting on our relationship and
our anniversary and then I'm I happen to
know my death date from a Vedic chart
that I had done from one of the
world-renowned chakrapani's in the Vedic
chart there are very very much
information I mean specific things like
children's birth and the years that I
built houses are in my chart the years I
divorce like it's all there it's all
there so I managed to get my death date
so and it's in a ways so I'm fine but
all right I'm be around but I was
laughing because you know if you're
gonna be on the planet as some of your
guests are talking about living to like
a hundred and twenty or I don't know
isn't there somebody you know I don't
really want to live that long so I have
you know another you know twenty seven
years and I was cracking up thinking of
what what twenty seven years like what
what is going to take up twenty seven
years and you know there's a whole
evolution of a whole nother experience
that's there and it's like we're at this
exciting time on the planet when there's
so much constriction and so much
opportunity to create things that are
beyond what we've ever known and I know
that as a divine privilege and within
the masculine feminine energies which
can be residing in any one male or
female there is an opportunity to
understand
maybe a more expansive story about how
those energies interact and so bringing
it back to everything you have is within
yourself you we all have everything that
we need within our own beings and as we
embody more of our life form we are able
to choose to dance with others in
certain ways but it comes from a place
of complete sovereignty so that's what
I'm interested in exploring with you in
this next phase all right
I think that's a good place to end it
for today okay beautiful yeah
thank you can I talk a little bit about
a couple things yeah I know I wanted to
ask you about water tiger okay first
things first and foremost and then
there's something else I wanted to yeah
so well that sort of that essence and
you know about I think when I came on
the show in August I was I was still I
was going through a rebirth and I had
mixed feelings about even coming on your
show and then so many people reached out
and they were happy that I was on so at
least the ones that I heard I'm sure
there were others that were you know
hating on me but anyway so but I went
through a really sort of transformation
when I was sort of observing or
reflecting on all these different
traditions that I've studied with and
different masters that I've been with
and just different tools and techniques
and perspectives and what I've realized
is from the whole group of everyone that
really comes down to your own
perspective and one of my most beloved
revered Indian Saints is a woman named
anandamayi ma and her name actually sri
anandamayi ma and i love this also
because my spiritual name is ma ananda
Srimati so we have every syllable the
same except one and she was born
realized and just really the energy of
Divine Mother and such a magnificent
energy she never worked like she just
existed in in radiating high vibrational
energy and people came to see her she
was a
none sent from the beginning right she
was just yeah she was basically just
born born awake and she did nothing but
just radiate love and people created
phones around her but she was just in
her divine state but she said this one
quote that is one of my favorite quotes
and that is every man is right from his
own point of view and of course that
means woman too but if you look at that
it's like everything is all about
perspective and so here I was I have a
birthday coming up on Sunday I've been
on the planet for many many years I'm
gonna be 57 on Sunday and what I what
have I gained from 30 years of spiritual
exploration in all these different rooms
with different teachers and different
traditions and what I had realized with
that was that everyone has their own
perspective so if I know that everything
is divine and I know that you are divine
and I know that I am divine and we all
are divine then I came into this body
for a purpose there is a purpose in here
of why I'm alive otherwise I wouldn't be
alive
so I turn my lens to really find this
perspective I'm really interested in
this perspective that this life-form has
rather than comparing to other
traditions or this is the way the
Buddhist did it or this is the way the
you know Vedic tradition does it or I'm
more interested in in me as a as a
life-form of nature and so this is where
water Tiger came from so being able to
merge into a natural form where there is
no need for validation you're not trying
to convince another life-form to be how
you are you're not writing books saying
you know it's really great to be a tiger
and everyone should be a tiger you're
simply in the exploration of your own
heart and so I launched an online
spiritual mentorship group called water
tiger and it's been an extraordinary
experience I'm doing a monthly call
which is on a timely topic then I answer
questions from everyone there's a forum
and you can go into the portal and put
all of your questions and then I offer a
dedicated key
technique and these are collection of
minimal very accessible and very
powerful techniques that one can use to
transform their life and it will lead
you into your own individual resonance
so I'm not really fostering interaction
between the members because we have so
much of that everything that we're
listening to is out outward focus so
this is all about inward inward focus
and it feels really really good it's a
very strong community already just after
two months and it's been extraordinary
so that's really really been amazing
yeah I think this is the culmination of
your life's work in in motion and
expression and it's been really
beautiful and cool to see you build this
thing and and your own and cultivate
your own community that you can speak
with directly and and and I think it's I
think it's also you know talking about
continual evolution like it's a it's a
it's a bizarre kind of quixotic thing
that you became like the plant-based
chef and like known as you know there's
like vegan cook write all these
cookbooks because knowing you like that
is a very small aspect of of who you are
the larger a larger picture is is what
you get to express through this new
platform and it's exciting that you know
people can meet you on that level and I
think this you know if people are
listening to this conversation or
watching it and they're connecting with
you I mean it's you know it's kind of
obvious that this is what you are this
is your purpose and this is what you're
here to do yes thank you yeah I am I
mean I'm a spiritual way show or guide
or frequency a lot of people feel the
energy of the mother from me and I've
many many many people who come to me who
have lost their mothers or are feeling
that support and and so that's it and
it's in whatever I do
if it's my music or if it's in my food I
I don't do it I do it to share the
frequency of this spiritual connection
so hopefully it ignites a remembrance
and those who are ready or those who
want that whether its food or some kind
of you know sort of verbal offering
these are just these are all divine
offerings right in two different forms
it's all for that m'kay one of the
things of the retreats it's been so
magnificent is that the people that come
are largely people that follow you and
that are coming to run with you or eat
plant-based food they're like oh I'm
going to check out Julie's yoga class
and what's been really profound to
witness is the depth of experience that
these people have had after working with
me for the week and going through the
spiritual transformation and the
practices and I want to just mention I
mean these are not people who have
practiced yoga their whole life or who
are lifelong meditators some are but
many of them are very very new to the
idea of spirituality just sort of
reawakening the idea that they are a
divine person and to see the sort of
breadth of experience at such a deep
deep level
it was truly just the divinity of
beginner's luck or be you know the
naivete of like a child and I had to
remind them you know people meditate
their whole lives to have some of these
experiences you guys had this week and I
think that's what that's what we are I
mean at one point early on before
anybody was listening to us we had
printed a business card and you were the
physical side and I was the spiritual
side and I think that it that that's
what it is it's like you provide a
portal for those who are interested so I
want to encourage people to not create
this mystique around spirituality like
oh I don't understand it or it's only
for a few what I'm doing with water
tiger is very I mean it's very deep I
don't I don't hold back so you're going
to have your mind blown but I am getting
very visceral techniques techniques that
are like embodiment that put your
awareness
in your body that bring your body organs
online to communicate with each other
techniques that sit you in front of the
mirror and get you to look at yourself
and really work out all that resistance
and everything that you're hiding so all
the techniques are very very accessible
and and functional and they work for a
modern life and what's going on with the
cheese oh my gosh so this is can you
talk about that yeah I can yeah I can
actually so I am launching a commercial
cheese line I may have I may have
mentioned it I was in talks with some
big corporate companies and taking
meetings with people talking about how
this company should be and it started to
feel very constrictive and very not in
alignment for me and so I kind of went
away from everyone and went into my own
experience and I decided to create
cheese's art with all the devotion and
the love and the taste and the beauty
that I want in this product and we
should just point out for new listeners
or viewers we're talking about
plant-based cheese that's right
plant-based cheese so I a book a few
years ago called this cheese's nuts and
I spent two years creating a technology
of creating plant-based cheese's I'm
extremely proud of this work and the
taste of the cheese is extraordinary
it's it fulfills and satisfies every
need that you have for dairy cheese and
it's free from fillers and the weird
gooey gums and like the whole wheat sort
of weird vegan cheese you know category
but like everything I'm a designer
fashion designer artist so it has to be
seeped in devotion and spirituality and
it has to be amazing design and it has
to be extraordinary taste so since I
published the book I've had enough
public events where I've served the
cheese for you know hundreds of people
that are not plant-based and I've seen
it approved so I know the taste ends up
and I have people that have tasted my
cheese two years ago that are still
thinking about it and I I have a very
amazing talent to create these cheeses
so I have developed a brand and the name
is Sri Moo it is actually yes I'm
actually saying it sure whether I wanted
to go I'm going to and I'm gonna give
actually a link where people can sign up
for subscription boxes so they can
there's gonna be a just a landing page
where they can go and just put their
email in and then when I launch I will
get to them so this is going to be an
offering it's a collection of cheeses
and because I'm a fashion designer that
if you want my cheese you have to buy
the collection so it comes in a box of
six flavors a couple of those will
probably be customizable but it's an
extraordinary collection it has boo dot
almond boo dot that's called babe it
comes floating in a it's in a jar
floating in coconut milk the next flavor
is called cloud nine and it's nine balls
of cashew mozzarella and they're
floating in crystal waters I have
another flavor called bonfire and this
is not your grandmother's cheese ball
but it's like a beautiful ball of smoked
almond cheddar that has an out sight
layer of activated charcoal I have
another flavor that's called birdy which
is a camembert flavored cheese that is
the star of every cheese board and then
I have two other flavors one is called
spire and this is a spirulina divine
aged cheese and then the sixth one is
called elder and this is a an aged
creamy just beautifully aged cheese with
activated charcoal also layers in that
so this is all packaged in magnificent
branding which I created with my friend
Bryan O Hara who did this and actually
this coating on this water bottle
so Bryan has read and written backwards
his entire life and so I asked him to
take the word devotional offering and
create a high road
for a pattern using that phrase so for
me it's not cheese it's a devotional
offering so it's called Sri Sri mu s RI
mu yeah do life
devotional offering of life and it's not
cheese right okay
why Sri mu well Sri mu because it was
kind of interesting because a lot of
people I had worked with you know of the
guys from people from headspace were
like you know you should come up with a
really catchy name and they liked the
name not cheese which is a great name
that would be a great name and I bought
the URL for that and then there was some
other names that were thrown out you
know by my previous partner that were
all nice names but I kept going back
into my own Divine Design and the fact
that I was given the name Ananda Srimati
I didn't ask for it and Indian master
gave me that name and it means Divine
Mother I mean it means more than that
but that Srimati means Divine Mother and
within my chart people want me to feed
them and within my Vedic chart my birth
is associated with the form of the cow
so the cow is divine to me and when I
went in to film the cover for this
cheese is nuts
I called gene Baur and asked him if I
could go to Farm Sanctuary and I was
invited in to work with the cows I
brought Jaya and when we arrived the
handlers were in very serious and they
were like Jaya can't come in the ring
and if this cow runs at you run this way
and if this cow charges you do this and
I said well can I put my arm around the
cow and they were like wouldn't advise
it and I was thinking wow this is not
what I had expected and these cows are
massive
oh they're huge huge huge huge cows
because we usually kill them before we
see them in their full expression so I
just was like okay they were like one
photographer can come in that's it so I
did a little quick breath work just real
fast kind of created a field walked in
and as I walked in they all started
lying down and then the handlers started
to relax and then I said can I put my
arm around them and they said yes so
there I was lying with these cows
basically like dogs kissing them
we got amazing photos and when I was
walking out I said to the handlers I
said thank you so much
for inviting me for this experience and
one of the boys looked at me and he said
no thank you for reminding us who these
beans are and I didn't quite understand
it but the next day I received a letter
from Lindsay one of the managers at Farm
Sanctuary and she said Julie we have
never seen the cows receive a first-time
visitor the way they did you yesterday
and she said you literally had them on
their knees so there is this proof I
always joke that they're like dude she's
making nut cheese like chill her out you
know but but it's like you know I don't
know then you know I didn't know that
that I had that form associated with my
birth so I go about I kept going back to
the origin of Who I am and the purpose
of what I want to do I want to create
beautiful artisanal delicious cheese
that give anyone who is looking for an
alternative to cheese an option and I
want them to be made fresh I want them
to be you know something that is divine
and so they're offered in an offering
box almost in a sacred box they have the
word devotional offering on them they're
infused with my love of life my love of
this planet and of cows and so that's
where Sri moo came from you know I've
thought about Srimati you know could
have been Srimati like mother's cookies
you know that also could have worked but
I really like Sri Moo Bryan like the way
that it works graphically and I feel
that in the end it's divine and it's a
perfect name well this is very exciting
and I've watched this evolve from the
sidelines for quite some time and the
process of iterating on this idea has
been you know an extended thing it's not
like you just woke up and like went
running through this like you've really
sat with how you want to express your
vision through these food products for a
long time to arrive at a place that
really feels true to who you are and I
think you've done that so I'm excited
for this to finally be publicly
available sand
I didn't I didn't know that you were
gonna actually say publicly what the
name is I know now I'm committed better
get that landing so this is what yeah
like if we have a landing page up when
is it going to be okay so the forum is
this in order to keep it authentic to
what I'm doing and to you know keep the
production at the level that it has to
be at so what I'm doing is I am starting
a subscription I am considering doing an
exclusive with one retailer I won't say
who the name is and it's a very
reputable you know just like the
ultimate store that's in this space but
my model is is subscription to begin a
direct and considerate consumer so I'm
looking for interest I'm looking for
orders that are basically shippable so
it would be you know in California and
in the US unfortunately I can't ship
internationally right now however that
is coming I mean that is in the business
plan so we're beginning you know there
are future things that are down the line
like a flagship store and you know
ultimately one of my dreams would be to
offer sort of franchise that people
could open cheese shops all over the
world and I could share this technology
in this this ability with with people
everywhere and give them a means to
actually make a living and you know Paul
Hawking of Paul Hawkens
if I can Hawken of drawdown project one
of the things that he shares is that in
order to shift the culture or you know
shift consciousness we need to give
people a way to make a living so that's
kind of the long-range view but before I
begin that the product you know I'm
going to be shipping out you know a
couple hundred boxes of subscription
cheese within the first three months and
then after that I'll raise that to
another you know another level and at
the same time you know we're in the
workings of creating a flagship store
and and you know we're gonna be getting
information and those of you who
subscribe early on you're gonna be
feeding you know we're gonna be getting
information from you but I will say that
I am very pleased with the review of the
product well the product is rocks
I mean the cheese is insane you know
aspires my favorite it's kind of like a
blue cheese everything that you make is
extraordinary and very different and
better than any other plant-based cheese
product that I've ever tasted it's not
even close like and and I think everyone
who has experienced your cheese's would
agree and of course I'm biased but but I
think it is the truth so I'm excited for
this and if people want to go to this
landing you should go it's just gonna be
on my website Julie Payette comm and
it'll probably be backslash Shri mu but
you could look in the tab and just look
for sri move it'll probably say Sri mu
not cheese and then click on that and
there'll be a form where you can enter
your information if you want to be
contacted when I launch and so it's
going to be on a yearly subscription and
I'm i you know the the initial idea is
that there would be six boxes a year so
you're not getting I mean you know again
we're talking about cheese I mean I
would love for you to eat cheese every
day but not really you know it's like I
want you to eat healthy plants and you
know we're not meant to be devouring
boxes of cheese every day I know that if
you bring my box into your home once a
month you will be your life will be
elevated and you will enjoy this amazing
blessing really somebody just order like
hot you're expecting them to order for a
year when they've never tried it though
can they just get a box and try it first
I don't know I don't know all right
probably not probably not I mean I
probably would be that you know they I
don't know I need to talk to my business
partner about that because I don't I
don't want to say anything that's not
but now the idea is it's been proven I
mean the thing is is between the people
that have eaten my cheese at plant par
Italia if you guys have seen like the
insta stories and everything going on
there you know we we have a big body of
individuals I think that are waiting for
the cheese that are ready to order it
you know so maybe you don't want to be
the first off and if I do do an
exclusive with this one retailer then
you could taste the cheese in that in
that area the other idea is though that
I would be doing pop-up events
because I'm really I'm really interested
in this community of drawing people
together so another thing that is part
of the mission is that I would do a
pop-up event where I would come and you
could taste the cheese so yeah they'll
be there will be an ability to taste the
cheese unless you don't live in
California and I'm not flying most
people but you know I don't know so
we'll have to see how it all pans out to
be revealed but in the meantime Julie
pie accom is the place to go I'll put a
link in the show notes and in the
description beneath the youtube version
of this when you have this specific URL
so people can go there to do that and if
they want to explore the universe of
water talk or how do they do that
going to julie payette calm and it's
there's a tab that says water tiger or
its backslash water tiger and you'll
scroll down you'll see a very
interesting photo of me painted like a
tree pregnant seven months in the dark
that is actually me so don't be afraid
don't be afraid just keep scrolling down
the other thing is I did want to mention
that if anybody wants to listen to that
song that I spoke of that's associated
with Lou's passing you can find my album
on my site under the music tab and also
on iTunes and Spotify it's Srimati and
it's a mother of mine in the track is
called in the Sun alright and those
links also go up in the show notes and
in the description so all right rich
role I love you
love you too I'm so happy you're gonna
be together now I guess we are a while
are we you think we are I mean you know
alright yeah well probably at least
until a moment arises to do another
podcast okay well that's good that's the
pact that gives us some stability all
right cool Larry you want to take us out
peace plants namaste
[Music]